what do you think I mean it didn't have
you on for medical advice etc but what
is your take on knowing what you know
about Hong Kong and other places what's
your take on what the fallout will be
from this in terms of number of
restaurants that will fold because if
you have a lot of penetration these
areas I'm sure you gave people a month
or two off for their bills yes yep
you had to do that proactively or and
for certain areas of the country or
certain areas of the world we have
actually waived fees through the end of
the year Wow
so that's really difficult so you've got
to deal with this crazy crisis managing
people working from home all this
craziness and then you have to turn off
your revenue stream in some cases oh my
lord that's brutal that's been what was
that board meeting like haha well I
think we we talked about you know the
brand we're trying to create
there's also market there's market
pressures where competition in the
market has given away their product for
free through the end of the year so you
have a decision to make about whether it
be try to match that or not and also
more so how do we lead I think the easy
decision was to meant to waive the fees
what we really are thinking about though
is our platform is gonna help operators
in the up and the down and actually this
is creating an opportunity for us
because we create restaurant
profitability if they're only relying on
third parties they can't own the
relationship they can't drive LTV they
can't drive profitability right so
they're gonna be more attuned to this
and also if they're only seating 50% of
as many guests they want those seats to
go to the ones who are gonna spend the
most money and there's going to be
demand what percentage of restaurants do
you think will not reopen do you have
any insight into that where people just
said hey take the machines back take
we're done yeah it's so early for us to
see and a lot of our segments 75 percent
of our customer base is actually
multi-unit enterprise so we've been a
little bit insulated that said across
the u.s. my guess is 30%
Wow one in three and despite all this
and that's why you're on the program
today is to announce that you did a 50
million dollar series be led by
Providence strategic growth I'm assuming
that that deal was in the works before
the pandemic hit
yes and then the pandemic hits when
you're you hadn't closed it at that
point in March we had this and it would
you when did you close May June it's
like right around now it's all blurry
yeah May G end of April beginning a bit
so you're working on this fifty million
dollar DL this is obviously a very big
investment firm to be able to write that
check does all of a sudden everybody sit
down at the table and reach raid and say
hey it's a new reality we got to cut the
valuation we want these extra terms or
is it just hey you know we made the
commitment we're gonna go straight
forward how do you negotiate a giant
deal like this and then having the
pandemic blow up right in the middle of
it yeah that was you know one for the
one for the books
yeah sure you know it was something that
I got a lot of advice on and really you
know no answer definitely more directly
starting with what's most important we
we went after the round
opportunistically luckily we didn't have
to raise the round and we had built
relationships with many of the investors
that we're talking to as you know
because most companies do long yeah for
when the pandemic hit we were still
early in the term sheet more or less it
was done but still early enough and some
of the terms they get retrained to
reflect the market realities right you
know and it was give-and-take you know
really turn conversations ultimately was
a Stila win so a significant up round
from our last valuation and luckily you
know we have our current investors as
well as PSG coming in that really
believe in the company so it wasn't what
we started but it was still great a
great outcome